[Music]
my friend mike diva just always has the
best youtube videos where he like to
show you when you hang out and he showed
me a music video that i really enjoyed
and i think ren's gonna like it so i'm
gonna play it for ren and see what he
thinks based on the fact they had a
documentary crew there to capture this
and try to make it seem real and they
got a little interview at the end it
makes me feel like it was staged or
it was a [ __ ] but then in the
middle of it so we got the bright idea
and there was like okay cool let's do
that
young thug he's the the classiest rapper
are you paying attention paying
attention you're the most important back
story
this is ryan stocky oh wait no i missed
it this is ryan's okay
but we never met each other i was
initially sent a recording of him
explaining his idea for the video to his
team wait no i heard about this video
is this the one that he didn't show up
to i haven't seen this
[Music]
[Applause]
i believe it but he didn't show up do
you think it was all technically set up
are there two things either two things
happened
they set this up before
or they forced him to by taking away
some other significant thing in his
contract
and made him put this video out yeah go
to the documentary go to the vice
documentary we're in a mansion in the
hollywood hills waiting on young thug to
arrive
actually
four now the police cars and like
regular windows
the uh of course he was there
he fits right in look at that he's even
wearing the exact same shirt he wore
when he came here pretty bad you should
ask him about this it's been about four
hours we're gonna text him right now and
ask him if in fact
that was real or staged dude how's it
going
good man how's it been i'm doing this
funny thing right now with the rest of
the guys at corridor and we watched this
young thug video and we saw the behind
the scenes footage
i know exactly what video you're talking
about yeah uh you're you're on speaker
by the way
awesome he just sat in the driveway and
didn't get out of the car
but he so did he show up late
was the whole thing set up
it was a real video dude it was legit i
mean like he could he came he showed up
he was in the car he was in the driveway
and then all of a sudden
oh no
you cut out right at the crucial the
crucial moment if that was planned that
way or if that was
most definitely not planned that way
i guess actually you confirmed it you
confirmed that it was true
so there you have it turns out the music
video is in fact real
wow
that was great that was great first-hand
information yeah what's next wrestling's
real
let's call it the rock yeah the skull of
the rock
he had his number yet okay
[Music]
nick had some concerns that we might
lose track of our subscribers and quite
frankly since you guys mean so much to
us we didn't want to forget about you so
we came up with an analog system to keep
track of it and we're going to put it
right above this door right here what do
you think i think that's a good spot for
it let me take a step back
a little bit to the right
do you need a hand uh i'm gonna do it
the jank way and see if it works keep
track of your followers on any platform
there's a link in the description with a
10 discount code not straight
all right it's a little crooked we're
within the jank factor
we're good now let's plug it in and see
what happens
98 percent goodness
you're getting a two percent drink
we got 10 more
you guys
it's working
man look at this cable management system
what is this
that's not annoying at all
it's like the sound of the ticker at the
new york stock exchange just think of it
that way vision and excellence
fun
you don't look convinced
we've been losing subscribers for the
past day
because actually you don't put a video
up for like a month or two months uh
when the first video hits and especially
something as controversial as
anatomically correct spiderman
you're going to lose subscribers sick
seven and a half eight
it janked up
they didn't print for the second day
oh that's why you uh
so that every time carmichael looks up
he sees it
how about that oh dang we're at 650.
well i can do the i can do this uh the
corridor once it has the youtube logo
but it just it abbreviates to 4.19
oh hold on let me fix that
good job
i think we could hit a million
subscribers this year mm-hmm oh yeah
20 of them [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] like bad [ __ ]
and i wanted to be like
any one of them
[Music]
for the breaks